there is
um harvard lecturer uh i think she
clarifies that she is not actually
professor carol hooven
uh who joined fox and friends for uh
joint that's their language that she
would not say that she's you know she's
a she's a liberal
um who spoke to fox for a four or five
minute clip
um to talk about the ideology that is
happening in
um in education and specifically the
middle school medical school
specifically the harvard medical school
and i think they found her through um
katie herzog's recent excellent piece
that was in barry rice's
sub stack so that's a that's a lot of
names um but
dr hooven here talks about male and
female being different
and us being able to talk about men and
women being critical in a medical school
and being able to say things like
pregnant women
and i will i will link to this in the in
the show notes but rather than have you
listen to the whole five minutes
you know i listen to it it's not that
long um and there's
exactly nothing transphobic or harmful
in what she says
and yet here we have someone um
tweeting out this video saying a woman
by the name of laura simon lewis saying
as the director of the diversity and
inclusion task force for my department
at harvard
heb that's um human evolution and
behavior i think
i am appalled and frustrated by the
transphobic and harmful remarks made by
a member of my department in this
interview with fox and friends um to
which i re
i quote treat it as an evolutionary
biologist i am appalled and frustrated
by the scientific illiteracy that is
apparently being facilitated by our most
elite institutions
um i don't
i don't honestly know how we are going
to continue
to function if this continues i mean
this
we're seeing incompetence and inability
to think through
basic scientific arguments over in
virus and vaccine space
at least that's a little bit complicated
at least it takes
walking through a few steps of logic to
arrive where people should
be arriving at but the
observation that everyone on the earth
has made
that male and female are different and
the
fact that in our lineage alone we have
at least
500 million years of uninterrupted
sexual reproduction in our lineage
and sex has been around sexual
reproduction has been around for
oh anywhere from one to two billion
years on the planet and probably our
uninterrupted lineage
goes back that far as well that 500
million years
number that i quoted that's just that's
me being conservative
like yes intersex people exist and
yes gender and here you and i always
have a slightly different um
definition for this gender is the
behavioral manifestation of sex
in non-human animals what we call uh
gender in humans we call sex role
and you know the way that you manifest
your sex
is your sex role is your gender are
there some humans
who feel deep down that they
are not the sex that they are born to
yes
and they are transgendered and we will
treat them with respect and we need to
do so but
this this has got to stop this has got
to stop this is insanity
it's it you're absolutely right it is
going to
result in the destruction of everything
as
as we pointed out long time ago
um you know if your schools of
engineering
are going postmodern then the point is
you're
giving an advantage to any competitor
who can manage not to suffer that same
fate right and so basically we're
talking you know on a global scale
of those societies that can resist this
nonsense are going to have
you know the gates of the city thrown
open to them
true but but in the meantime bridges may
start falling right
and in the meantime as medical schools
are captured and cannot agree to
like really the easiest and most basic
observable fact of human biology
right i mean if they started saying that
humans have three legs i'd find that
more plausible
right right if if this is gonna
this is gonna be killing people because
guess what as we you know as we go
through the evidence you know very very
briefly in a different part of this
chapter
you know the number of medical
conditions
that manifest differently not just in
frequency
but in but with regard to etiology that
is what causes them and with regard to
symptoms how they manifest
bisex is huge and growing all the time
and a that's going to start disappearing
we're not going to be able to know about
it the research isn't going to be
allowed
and people are going to arrive in
hospitals presenting
with things where if you don't even get
to know as a doctor what sex
is we're going and it's and it's largely
frankly probably
going to affect more women than men so
just as just as
the vast majority of medical research
until the mid 20th century was done
on on men and it was assumed that what
was true for men was true for everyone
it was pretty recently that we started
seeing
a recognition that men and women
revealed disease differently
and this improved women's health care
well this is just going to take us right
back
well i think it's even worse than that
you know
yeah well of course
if you think about the game that we play
politically
right where we force you to effectively
engage
in a career of uh legal corruption
before you can get to the highest
echelons of
leadership right so we force you to
prove that you will make the mental
the moral compromises in order to play
that game
before we ever learn your name as a
senator or you know presidential
candidate or anything like that
in this case it's effectively imagine
that what we did was we just said okay
from now on we are going to ask people a
question
before we let them into medical school
do you agree that men can get pregnant
right and if the answer is well no
men can't get pregnant sorry you're not
qualified for medical school
right then you get a medical school in
which everybody agrees men can get
pregnant the question is what is the
quality of what will take place at a
medical school where you had that as a
gate
right right the answer is that's not
going to be much of a medical school
because what you've just done
is demonstrated that everybody there is
a coward
or a fool or some combination of those
things
and if you you know build a medical
school of cowards and fools it's not
going to be a high quality one so
at some level you have to empower people
to be able to say look
i get it that it's really unpleasant
that there are you know two sexes and
that we can distinguish them
uh you know immediately on birth except
in very rare
cases right um but the fact is
come on you cannot allow these things to
take over essential functions and
essential functions
means not only things like medicine and
governance
but also things like the military right
increasingly we are feminizing our
military which
you know from the point of view of us
empathizing better with each other
there's an argument to be made for
from the point of view of the ability
to have a you know unique gender profile
what you really need is a
powerful masculine military to protect
the freedom that allows you to figure
out how you want to live
right if you say well that freedom
should exist in the military too and
why is this military regimen you know so
dictatorial shouldn't it be democratic
and
you know shouldn't we figure out you
know let's not make a military move
until everybody's had a chance to speak
right
i mean you can imagine applying these
rules being well-intentioned but my god
you're going to create a system that
cannot
function yeah chain of command goes
right out the window yeah it sure does
[Music]
you